[Music]
soak it in welcome back to another
chapter of dirty RT season 2 chapter 14
I'm Rob joined here with Jake and this
my friends is the Valentine's special
yeah they might recognize who we've got
riding the horse here well obviously
it's 30 rd but they might remember which
style dirty RT it is that's right
we're going back to an older save where
already has no clothes because in this
episode we're gonna play the part of
cupid cause playing cupid cause playing
cupid we're going to make people fall in
love ideally two people fall in love
with each other as you can see we've got
a bow and some arrows lots of arrows
lots of arrows lots of different types
of arrows so we'll have our Arsenal
stocked in order to play a part of a
cupid but before we start making people
fall in love we're gonna have to go find
a nice piece of clothing we're just not
gonna take you home yeah we're not going
to you can come with us but as I was
saying we are going to find a nice piece
I think
shut up nice piece of clothing to really
like seal the deal some some red nice
leather maybe like a vest get off
no one saw perfect yeah we're gonna see
what we can find here as far as clothing
I'm hoping I'm hoping the the red vest
will work because that's the thing is
like when as we know that not all
clothing will work for this bug yeah
assless chaps do just fine maybe if
there's a red version of that that would
know it sued the reactions I'm certain
like they like freak out when you come
in oh all right what else what else do
we need oh yeah that's right
what like happens when we purchase this
does he just have no legs now we're
gonna find out I guess that kind of
plays into the role of Cupid he's kind
of you know mystical in a way ya know
maybe flies yes all right I think we're
set damn I wish we could look like that
little Lord there I like this more
because I don't see whatever is in his
crotch are you yeah that's true I lost
my legs
Steve Steve - Steve - is back let's see
- it's a different timeline yeah the 30
Rd timeline is an absolute disaster how
did Steve to die I think you got hit by
a train what the hell oh no something
like that or we fell off a ledge with
him I don't know he's died a lot though
love is in the air
[Laughter]
he's a Galloway for sure oh I like that
a lot
now we're cooking love true love true
love god damn it I'm a cupid Oh
we were in San Denis for what a minute
yeah oh my god why don't we go to
Valentine oh yeah hi I didn't quite
think of that you know I feel bad for
that town you know all the things that
we've done they need love they they get
all of dirty arty you know like these
other towns just every now and then
dirty already shows up yeah but
Valentine gets the brunt of it yeah you
know we should also do we should go to
the camp and intimidate our gang members
yeah because that's something people
have been asking for since like Episode
four and we haven't done it dirty arty
also hasn't been the camp in what three
months who are all you people there he
is there's that but guess it's Valentine
then yeah all right unless we want a
nice little hat oh yeah oh yeah I feel
like I don't have a dick this guy looks
like he could be part of a circus oh
this is such a brat away nose he's
annoying this guy what's your problem
[Laughter]
no bad moving their whole back and
nothing you could do your hand
he thought I was gone didn't you I'm the
cupid [ __ ] get your one room where I
put this thing on your beyond to me man
this is kind of a big moment for our
dirty arty I know I'm free I'm intrigued
I wonder what they're gonna think of you
well I know I'm a little different a
little different man walkin around
talkin [ __ ] with your pants off I
actually don't think I've ever gone to
camp and just antagonized everyone I've
done it to a couple people I've started
fights in camp problem is it you like
you can't take it to the logical level
of shooting them yeah go-to for dirty
arty see my friends again
I have no idea oh it's John oh good
someone's sleeping easy there now you're
Xavier squalor great bounty hunter and
revolutionaries you're one to talk
wish I could say you were still fine for
some but ain't so sure you think this is
funny I'm sleeping off you can swag
around all you want but you're still a
kid that was a good bluff on Xavier oh
we got thrown out well let's go rap
again can't get rid of me that easily
how many times you pissed yourself today
hard living al age a woman fast just
look at Grimshaw there is the camp pig
minding my own business here no wonder
we're always short of food why are you
doing this you eat it all look at you
you goddamn poser
oh not this again there's no pants
antagonizing [ __ ] oh they took me
further away this time
no matter hasn't stopped me
[Laughter]
fighting him and knock him out was so
cool I love that he's totally reasonable
like fine taking like the upper left
there you got other things you could be
doing yeah you could like Rob places or
literally anything else anything else if
you want
you're just saying I'll come back for
you what are you talking about a low
Dutch judge I need you don't smile your
face might crack is this meant to be
some joke just means you are look at you
all further piss and vinegar you all
right well should we I don't know I only
think we can find I don't think we can
find Dutch I don't think so either
should we just go to Valentine's and go
to Valentine have some people fall in
love and yeah and end it on a nice
Valentine's Day special you guys are
real NSYNC where's the I think they're
in love I think they're in love a
coalition my love potion
I think it worked I think they loved
each other
dang there's a storm yeah because we
just did all those evil deeds yeah all
that [ __ ] talking back at camp it's
upset the gods
[Laughter]
there is home sweet home smell Valentine
that's sweet mud happy Valentine's Day
Valentine well I'll keep the horse Oh
chance Day gift to you I'm hungry
any games with chocolates or Valentine's
chocolates there are so many things to
do that's mighty popular these days
enjoy yeah yeah yeah the whole lot
[Laughter]
better hope so chocolate what now weird
in can I get you anything else
Oh feels so good on my skin oh my bare
skin my bare bottom yes
happy Valentine's Day about a snow cloud
this is I think it's making it hard for
them to work that stable caretaker
really hates you dang it dirty Artie's
on the roof again they're in love don't
worry your love to we're dead
let me guess it's dirty those two look
at them
I think they've been in love they just
need to rekindle their love mm-hmm
[Music]
no here turn around perfect somehow
don't know what's happened they can't
find me that's a lie bold-faced lie
making age to fall in love I'm gonna
kill him right in front of the police
guy oh oh he knew I was there who's just
waiting yeah yeah one ticket please
oh that's what you think
[Laughter]
who eats eat some beans jackal ad
slingshot it off this might be what my
favorite dirty already outfits and
there's been some really good ones yeah
survive survive survive thrive survive
ah well we tried we tried
we're gonna take a look at the huge show
us your arty Twitter feed all right here
we are looking at show us your Artie's
this marks a first Jake for the dirty
arty a milestone a milestone we have fan
art all thanks to blue Nova Corgi this
is outstanding really nailed it got the
beans fallen out of his mouth
the the horse screaming people on fire
actually all the mountains on fire I
think that right yeah I feel like that
was one maybe when the final touches
anything everything on fire I really
like how the horse like he's clearly
being abused and dirty Artie is just
triumphant fantastic thank you so much
very awesome
this one I just thought was fun and was
going on here in a way I'd like looks
like art he's getting a little too uh
intimate with that deer I just wanted to
know if there was any more backstory to
this maybe like oh there's no context
even see there's any more to this image
if it's the wrong image move lane or
maybe uploaded the wrong Oh
anyways I like that this one's pretty
awesome and I love that hat hat we might
need to find that hat and think of a way
to do it but there are a lot of fur
going on here very very awesome almost
like a Russian hat or something I don't
know you'd call it but that's cool from
a boss bridge 677 it looks like yeah did
we do this one no I don't think so I
think we've seen this mask before yeah
but he looks filthy looks filthy this
this looks like it looks like ash
covered he's just covered in ash like he
just came out of like a like a fire I'd
be terrified if I saw him walking around
definitely scary thank you
okay who was thanking - I got suck
or dredge I dredge Ike thank you dude
thank you very much yeah Ronna chickens
yep setting things on fire the hat looks
very simple a simple man a simple photo
and just a hint of a smirk like I did
this there's a there's a lot of pride
here is also another first is uh not not
quite a red dead dirty arty but my I
think it works he's a gunner look he's
got a six-shooter
oh she noticed that devil horns that
works makes sense that's amazing I love
that is that like Fox's fit I don't know
like yeah sick this was great
so he's probably at the doctor the
doctors behind him he seems surprised I
think I got it
[Music]
instead of Nell he sent us a lot yeah
super awesome
this one's clap just let a nice classic
selfie at the Viking yeah the classic
stuff with a viking helmet i know i know
what those are like thank you feel swift
for that and this nice is yeah right
this was a very well done some great
composition and camerawork be awesome
make like a comic you know like if
someone had the patience to make a comic
but he looks he doesn't even look like
art arthur morgan anymore no almost
almost
I'm getting a little bit of a Myka yeah
guy mustache for sure but also just like
the attitude and look look at the Hat
with the feather in the hair oh damn
that's good that's good that's good and
that's not safe how did you get on the
train yeah wait you're right I didn't
even notice that I thought it was on a
bridge for you're right that's a train
what impressive and on the other end of
the spectrum is just some freaking creek
I don't think I've seen that mask before
it's just like a skull I think we had I
think we've had a couple submissions
with MS
yeah I'm a little terrified and there's
our Shane Bolger Shane Bolger thank you
and there's our our weapon black or
black Smith we made friends with him how
we did looking cool with explosions
behind you from Mythbusters oh Jesus
that's what is Jamie Oh God that took me
way too long that's pretty sick he's
like spying on her but not doing it
correctly pretty cool pretending like
I'm not doing anything
ended blend in quick thanks tech
consumer this is awesome pirate already
know the pirate I like beard man that
beard is good it looks like a starfish
she looks like a starfish yeah it does
that's a cool photo on the left like
that looks like from a cinematic or
something yeah very cool Tom stoop home
stoop that's all of them that's it thank
you guys so much that was chapter 14
thanks Jake thank you everyone watching
we'll see you next week
show us your Artie's
[Music]